what are you most looking forward to
going into the house winning $500,000
get that money year so ready let's check
at the end it's a big amount of cash
what are we gonna do with it well my mom
is being very encouraging that I
invested it's David pay off my Nordstrom
credit card bills but I will probably do
a little bit of that and also I want to
start it go fun why have you not seen
goats so my parents just bought a farm
and they've been talking about building
the house they have a micro cabin right
now okay and so I get the micro cabin if
I buys in my house I'm gonna pay off my
mom's built-in house I'm gonna buy
myself a car cuz I earn Carlos I am
going to pay off my student loans and
I'm gonna travel around I probably pay
off my family's debts I mean I have them
like sad sign their houses over to me
you know help my family I want to give
back to them so I want to show them
appreciation take them on a vacation and
invest the rest if I win first place
when I win first place I'm immediately
splitting the money with my mom
I'd love to buy a new car and maybe you
just sit on the rest my first plan is
obviously my mom she she's done
everything for me and my family so I
want to be able to give back to her and
you know whether it'd be like taking her
on a trip just gonna pay off my mom's
mortgage and then anything left over
we'll go from there nice the cliche
answer I'm gonna help my family and I'm
probably also gonna fix my broken car
maybe like being my own bikinis like
professionally people always asking
about that so I can you make me one I'm
like no cuz usually it's me getting
naked and like putting on myself and
then sewing it and then like you're
turning on I don't wanna see you naked
son okay I'm not gonna save it I'm not
gonna like buy a house I'm gonna have
fun you know you know you can only live
what life once I'm gonna go out I'm
gonna go on adventures I'm not really
here for the 500k it could be 50k I
don't care I'm really here because I
love the game and because I'm ready for
the adventure I'll put it down payment
on a helicopter okay dream big I'll put
a deaf ear on a helicopter that can lift
2,000 pounds or more and I'm gonna I'm
gonna fly me and my bowl to the rodeos
obviously like some nice toy
like some fun toys some nice trips I'm
gonna take my family and friends on a
pretty dope family vacation and then I'm
gonna hire a financial advisor to help
me with investments and also savings my
sister's drowning and college debt so
I'd like to pay off her college loans
and buy myself a house if I win you'll
probably take my money any other dog
have a stomach pacemaker I have a fraid
to use club ketchup recess so if I won
the money I can't have children on my
own so I want to freeze my eggs I don't
want to have any regrets in the future I
know I want to have children so I want
the option to be there so I feel like
it's bigger than me I was raised by a
single mother my dad died when I was
young so I just want to give back and I
want to I want to make an impact it's
like um
children who is both hair and cast away
and single moms yeah just give back in
this hole
[Music]
Oh